-Welcome back.
-Thank you for having me back.
I wish they would have playe
something a little more funk
for me so I could twerk for you.
-That wasn't funky enough?
-Uh-uh. I want something
a little more funky.
-I hope they will
take that as a note
for the next time you're here.
-Yeah, I hope so.
Because I want to twerk
for y'all.
This is a little twerk dress
-Oh, my goodness.
You know, I got
my twerk boots on.
-I feel like --
[ Cheering ]
Like a real missed opportunity
for us.
-I mean, y'all know any, like,
2 Chainz, or...?
[ Laughter ]
Any Migos?
-It's just not going to
happen tonight.
-It's not -- twerking.
-It's just not --
it's just not
going to twerk out for us.
-Yeah, it's not going
to twerk out.
-It's not going to twerk out
[ Audience ohs ]
It is -- I was --
lovely to see you
the other night
at the Golden Globes.
-Oh, thank you.
-You presented with your co-star
in the film, Salma Hayek.
-Yes.
-Fantastic.
Did you enjoy -- You've been t
your share of awards shows
Did you enjoy the Golden Globes?
-I did enjoy it.
That was my first time eve
presenting there,
ever being in that room.
It felt like a really cool
high school assembly.
-It is.
[ Laughter ]
And that, by the way,
that's the absolute peak
of what an awards show can be,
is a cool high school assembly
-Yeah, but with alcohol.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It is -- of the awards shows
wouldn't you agree, it is
the most fun of all of them?
-I mean, I haven't been
to all of them.
-Yeah.
-But for what I've been to
that was great.
-Yeah.
Did you see -- did you run
into any people that you
had never met before,
that you were happy to see
-Yeah, I ran into Carol Burnett.
-Fantastic.
-And that was, like,
super awesome.
You know, she tweeted
about me before
because I had hosted
the MTV Movie and TV Award
and I had wore the curtain
and all that.
And so she tweeted
that she liked it.
And then, I was, like,
I had tweeted back.
But then, she didn't say
nothing back.
But then I had -- I had went
you know --
I saw her -- I was on the
carpet, and then I saw her
and I was, like,
"Do I approach her?"
Am I going to scare her
if I approach her?
And then, I was like,
"Forget it,"
I'm fixin' to just going
to just get in her interview
and see what happens.
-Yeah.
-And she was looking at me
crazy at first, like,
"Who is this black woman?"
And then I said,
"I'm Tiffany Haddish."
And then she was like, "Oh, hi!"
And she was nice to me.
And that is wonderful.
When your heroes are kind.
-Absolutely.
And she is right,
she is as kind as they come.
-Yes.
-You --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You gave an act of kindnes
at the after party.
You actually got up and rapped
-Oh, yes.
See, what happened was
I had been drinking some more,
right?
-You had been drinking
some more, yeah.
-I had been drinking some
more from being --
because my feet was hurting.
So then, you know,
when your feet hurt --
-So it was medicinal.
-Yeah, that's medicinal.
You know, I didn't have --
I didn't have
the CBD for the feet
that had wore off.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
-So then, I had smoked wit
Snoop Dogg, and then, I had --
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-Yeah.
I ain't gonna lie.
I'm going to tell the truth.
Because it's legal
in California.
I don't know about here.
But in California...
-Yeah.
-So then I had me
a little vodka, and then
I went into the Netflix party,
and I saw that the Netflix
party was a little --
it was not where it needed to be
energy-wise.
-Yes.
And now, this is a true story.
You used to have a job
as an energy producer.
-Yeah, I was a professiona
energy producer.
My job is to produce positiv
energy in any room I step in
Mostly boring bat mitzvahs
and some weddings --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Christmas parties
and things like that,
my job is to make it just pop,
and get the old people dancing
the young people dancing,
get everybody moving together.
-Multi-generational.
-Yeah, multi-generational,
across all age lines.
-Yeah.
-And, so, I walk into the party,
and I notice
it's kind of dead.
And, now, mind you, I had been
to four parties already
and asked every deejay
to let me get the microphone
nobody would let me get it
-Okay.
-But this deejay,
he was dumb enough
to let me get the microphone
[ Laughter ]
And I told him to play my song
I said, "Play 'Dripeesha'
by Todrick Hall
and Tiffany Haddish."
-Right, right.
-And he played it,
and I was like,
"He must be crazy."
And, so then, I just started
singing the song,
and then he plays
"City Girls."
And I guess he thought
I was going to give
the microphone back, but no.
I just start rapping on to
of "City Girls,"
even though I don't know
none of the lyrics to that song,
I just kept going --
I made my own lyrics up.
-And energy up?
Do you feel like you turne
the party around?
-Now, it looked like everybody
was dancing.
I seen cell phone lights.
When you see cell phone lights
it's either good or really bad
So --
[ Laughter ]
-It sounded like a good one?
-It felt really good.
It felt like people were
dancing and moving.
They was like, "Go, Tiffany,
go, Tiffany!"
And somebody yelled out,
"She got bars!"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's a very --
That's very high praise.
I think --
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't think --
I don't think there's even
an inkling of a chance
someone will yell out that I
have bars at a party ever.